Well then, let's try it on with a skirt Well,
maybe I should try it as much as I can Is this
okay?  I'm talking about it,
so what should I do? As
expected, I can't submit a photo of the full view of my cleavage,
so let's give
first aid.
It looks
like I'm going to fail, so I won't try to do it for you. First
, I'll cut a circle around my chest, then use a slightly
larger cloth to suck it out
.
I'll check it once in the mirror, wait a minute. Even if she's
still red-haired and she'll definitely die, she's still in the future.
I don't have a story, so I'll use what I
just
did and try to come again so that I ca
n't see even just my cleavage Yes, I can't see my cleavage anymore
.
[Applause]
No,
what can I do to make amends to you?